what we're looking at is we're
continuing with our year of events that
are connected to other events so
complementary events we know it's like
this or that and they sort of match up
together like a pair multistage events
are sort of like a virgin' effort on
steroids okay so what we do in many
situations like this Aquinas three times
right now you're going to get out of
there three results and I include them
all together as one event so it's like
one event and it's got all these
different parts in it stages right think
that once there but twice as they've
been good times
okay now the best tool you can use to
help you understand these is a
probability trigger you seen these
before
but I want to remind you of what they
look like okay so if you haven't written
down all these questions then leave a
bit of space but I do want you to pick
up your pens now huh and draw the tree I
about control I can't split three times
when you flip it the first time what's
the total sample space heads or tails so
the size is 2 so the way I'm going to
represent that is to say heads or tails
and I'm going to represent their
branching off because you're getting one
or the other right so it's like this or
this you can't get both at the same time
but after you flip the first head or
tail in fact we might like to label this
part the first bit you then flip again
you've got the next stage okay so let's
just imagine for a moment but then
actually best mod imagine he's got a
coin cuz I don't think
here we coins okay so I'm gonna put this
point right okay
it's heads its head let's imagine this
is what's happened okay son
after I do this I've gotta flip again
right so again there are two
alternatives right it could be a head or
a tail for the second clip okay are you
with me but of course we might not have
gotten hands ISM pretty even chance that
I had gotten tails so if this had
happened is there there's kind of like
this alternate reality over here where I
flipped tails instead and it has its own
set of outcomes that come along with it
okay so after two flips there are four
possible things that could have happened
I could have gotten two heads in a row I
could have gotten the head tail I could
have gotten a tail many head or both of
them could have been tails there are
four distinct different knuckles but I'm
flipping it three times right so I'm
gonna do the third and for each of these
four outcomes head head head tail tail
head tail tail I could get the head or
tail tail so I'm gonna do all of these
and I'll try my best to fit all of them
okay so you can see each of these
branches off from one of the outcomes in
the previous stage so this is my
probability tree diagram now I will
point out for this coin I'm assuming it
is fair right so the second one is going
to be tails again
and heads again so amazing we have a
three heads in a row okay but each time
I split there was going to be an even
chance of one of the other so that's why
you can see none of these branches
they're not labeled which I assume means
it's always even okay but I could have a
coin that's designed to flip on one side
more than the other so if I were like
it's slightly suspicious that I got
three days in a row
suppose it was twice as likely to get a
head versus a tail think about that for
a second if it were twice as likely to
get a head and a tail it should be
two-thirds and one-third but don't write
this because this is not actually the
case
at least those two so I could write
two-thirds one-third which indicates
yeah there's two outcomes but they're
not necessarily equal there was a
question you did earlier at Hope which
said tomorrow why the rain would not
rain does that mean there's an even
chance 50-50 chance of it raining or not
raining because what business do
outcomes two outcomes doesn't mean
they're the same pongo even if you're in
a desert or if you're in a rain forest
the outcomes are gonna be very very
differently probability right okay so
you can see if I want to I can label
these I'm not going to because they're
all even right now this thing here is
gonna really help us now let's look at
these questions right
oh don't list the sample space now I can
think of the sample space just off the
top of my head if I want to okay but it
becomes very hard to think about it in a
systematic way and make sure I don't
forget any thank you so I'm going to use
this probability tree and then over here
on the right hand side aren't going to
list the sample space because every
possible event that could happen is all
here in my tree I'm just going to follow
the branches so let's look at the one
that actually happened by chance I've
got a head and then a head and then head
so that is one of the options
right if I just keep on going down
that'll produce a nice system ate this
for me head and then head and then
what's this one head tail head tail tail
and you get the idea you can fill out
all of them in this way and the lovely
thing about using the tree is you know
you haven't missed anything there are
eight possibilities and they're all
there okay